[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui si melissa maulin depuis berlin par
la tonne alors cette semaine un sujet
que je veux absolument mettre de l'avant
c'est un sujet qui revient à chaque
année je suis né spacieux qui est
toujours aussi important et qui donne la
période dans laquelle on passe en ce
moment je prends avec la remontée des
codes coved avec le baril en
communiquerons et bien c'est ainsi on va
parler d'une population qui le plus à
l'aise et c'est la population itinérante
que ce soit à montréal ou un peu à
travers le canada on a vu qu'il y avait
des enjeux qui touchait particulièrement
justement les personnes en situation
d'itinérance et pourquoi
particulièrement je vais en parler cette
semaine c'est qu'on a vu dans les
dernières de trois semaines justement le
décès de heath avis prouteau qui est une
année de saint louis qui est décédé
morte sur un champ de construction et
ont dit après qu après enquête on en
saura plus mais il se parle il
semblerait qu'elle aurait été
évacués demandé de sortir du métro où
elle cherchait un îlot de chaleur pour
ensuite dirigé vers un site de
construction où elle a malheureusement
trouvé la mort et ce qui est vraiment le
plus enragé dans cette histoire c'est
que madame pour hugo qui étaient
descendus du nord au sud pour trouver
des soins de santé appropriés parce
qu'ils ne sont pas disponibles dans sa
région pourquoi est-ce que ça me met en
rage encore plus sexy en écho avec le
décès de raphaël andré que lui au début
du confinement qui cohabitent quand
justement la situation était totalement
inadapté envers les populations en
itinérance populations à risque celles
qui ne pouvaient pas justement s'isoler
rester à la maison raphaël en dhr on
s'en souvient et d'essai dans une
toilette chimique après avoir pas pu
retrouver justement les sites où il
allait pouvoir se garder une chance de
l'univers et bien sûr une somme mais
fier d'aller demander de l'aide aux
policiers parce qu'à l'époque nous
allons donner des tickets à ceux qui
étaient dans la rue ou ceux qui étaient
pas chez eux en confinement donc toutes
ces situations là me rappelle
constamment que non seulement déjà dans
une situation normale qui n'est pas une
situation de pandémie mondiale les
communautés qui sont dans des situations
différentes sont taris sont en danger
mais on rajoute un poids quand on
rajoute justement toutes les situations
je sais que la situation du confinement
a été allégé pour les populations qui
sont en situation d'itinérance je sais
aussi que le décès de raphaël andré up a
mené à la création de la tente raphaël
andré beaucoup plus de services ont eu
une présence au square cabot un lieu qui
est justement très fréquentés par la
population et itinérantes de montréal
cependant ça rajoute aussi d'autres
enjeux qu'on n'oublie calculé
premièrement je pensais juste au fait
que moi dans les dernières deux années
je me suis retrouvé j'ai pu donner
beaucoup moins de sous beaucoup moins
d'article je demande soit alimentaire ou
d'articles de vêtements à la population
en général parce que mauvais état en
confinement je me rendais - au
centre-ville donc je me suis dit six
mois en participant au moins par mon
confinement gênes - à alléger la
situation de personnes qui sont en
situation d'itinérance à montréal je
suis pas la seule donc la perte de
revenus qui vient justement des
personnes que vous croisez dans la rue
je pense aux camelots de l'itinéraire
qui doit vendre de moins en moins de
journaux justement parce que la présence
est aussi le désir des gens de ne pas
avoir de contact physique trop directe
avec des gens donc d'être ch est leur
moins d'être pansées fait en ligne mais
ne seront pas fait dans le final parce
que si on le sait c'est que camelot
quand même on y croise on lui donne aux
souffrants le journal c'est un geste
rapide et ça nous permet de chamant
d'encourager un médium comme l'éclairage
qui après ça donne des services
justement je prends ça court square
cabot je pense je veux rendre aux cafés
la caf et la maison ronde qui seront
soit cabot et toutes sortes d'autres
services qu'ils ont aussi bénéficié
beaucoup des contacts indirects avec les
gens le foyer des femmes autochtones de
montréal chez d'orist beaucoup levée de
fonds beaucoup de situations où on
encourage les membres des communautés se
font pour beaucoup de gens dont 10
millions de tonnes sur le terrain en
présentiel et en étant éloigné de la
communauté pêche me sur un tronc que la
participation à la communauté étaient
des immigrés et donc ça doit pas
vraiment alléger la situation des
personnes en situation d'itinérance
parce qu'il faut dire que c'est une
situation d'itinérance on n'est pas aux
itinérants ce n'est pas un titre c'est
une partie de nos vies parfois convient
momentanément parce qu'on est éloigné de
nos systèmes de sécurité comme dans les
communautés on compte beaucoup sur mon
système venu beaucoup sur nos systèmes
communautaires qui sont présents et
c'est d'ailleurs quelque chose qui avait
vraiment marqué mon coeur et mon
imaginaire c'est que j'ai mon chef qui
avait pas fait partager les paroles du
père de raphaël andré qui disait je
n'aurais jamais cru que mon fils en est
leur mort est elle un endroit où il ya
autant de bâtiments qu'ils pourraient
mourir de froid et c'est vraiment
marquant parce que chez les innu
l'attend est un lieu où on va partager
l'espace avec les gens c'est qu'un froid
c'est qu'enfin il ya toujours de
l'espoir dans une tente pour accueillir
quelqu'un ici en a pas on va en faire si
elle passe à manger on va le partager
pareil parce que demain cette personne
va nous aider après donc le système est
pas fait pour créer une clairance est
parfaite pour me donner un titre à
quelqu'un qui arrive dans la vente qui
t'aiment itinérant qui a pas de deux
maisons fixe donc vous comprendrez que
les différences c'est un truc qui a été
inventé donc pour aider justement les
personnes en situation
n'hésitez pas à donner à des organismes
n'hésitez pas à donner justement à
toutes les analyses que gène dénommé
parce que c'est une des périodes les
plus fragiles pour eux d'ailleurs on
n'est pas rien et les familles pendant
le temps des fêtes ça peut être encore
plus difficile de passer à travers des
situations comme ça et des services sont
offerts par les centres d'amitié
autochtones par exemple par les services
que vous parlez des fois une femme dit
n'être bon et des cetc personne n'a à
pouvoir trouver la porte de sortie d'une
situation qu'ils n'ont pas choisies ou
des fois qu'elles ont été un peu
bousculée donc je vous dis tout de suite
et du camp partager intéressez-vous
justement à ces organismes comme ça on
peut supporter la communauté avec un
filet comme les communautés ont toujours
eu le le
le plaisir de le faire pour les autres
alors je souhaite une belle semaine à
bon temps des fêtes n'hésitez pas à
partager notre vidéo et oublie pas il
est disponible seulement sur des
plateformes pour des partages un peu
multiples avec les gens qui vous savez
seraient intéressés par ce sujet bonne
semaine